- "Monica" is pretty personal for you,
this film is pretty personal, right?
- Oh, yeah.
I mean, every trans
story is personal for me.
"Monica," I mean, there's
so many Monicas out there.
I feel like our journey with our families,
and just where we fall in the world,
and how the world makes space for us,
or doesn't make space for us,
is always gonna be a fight
that we're gonna have to fight,
at least in my lifetime, probably.
But, this movie, it, you
know, it's for the girls,
it's for the dolls, it's
for the femme queens.
It's for the trans women that.
(audience applauds)
I have been waiting for so long
for their stories to be told.
It centers on her.
It's not centered on someone else.
It's through her lens,
which is very different.
Usually, you know, if
there's a trans person
involved in a movie,
they're not the protagonist,
they're not the centerpiece.
So, that's why this film is so special.
- But, that's why I said
yes, faster to this film
than any film I've ever
done in my very long career.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because, it was, kind of
still very emotional for me.
It was not lost on me, Kelly,
that it would give an
extraordinary transgender actress
the lead.
I said, I'll be your
backup singer any day.
I knew how important this film was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- What "Monica" does, is
deeply humanizes a trans woman
at the center of a story.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We are human beings deserving of love,
deserving of rights and respect,
and it's really about
a rehumanizing process
that has to happen in
relationship to trans people.
And, great storytelling is
a beautiful way to do that.